[Musique]
ici
maman et papa si tu danses à Oviedo
un gradin mais il vous laisse prendre un café et
prendre vie pour mon père
fort avec des objectifs mais prend des fichiers
mais valdés a rejoint ma coalition téléphonique
père, c'est pareil si je quitte Jodie Se
mettre dans les compositions rencontrer le bloc et
les jambes fortes sont libres
J'étais heureux de supprimer Isabel II et
seti jam ici tu sais
[Musique]
ils me soulèvent et les eaux deviennent brunes
arroser une panique à la langue pse-ee hé et
demande d'être d'accord même si pas même le café
façon jodi si ce n'est pas là, pense à ne pas t'arrêter avec
le thème du café à gaz
[Musique]
très affecté
comme personne
[Musique]
j'y retourne
de ce bout du pays
tu as perdu le PIB et si c'était un nouveau moment pour
indice mais la vérité me rend très vieux
[Musique]